what up you guys happy Thursday happy
happy Halloween I don't know what that
um so yeah we are here Halloween at the
end of our eight days of horror even
though we lost few days it's all good
okay it's expected of anywho we took
recommendations from you guys and
yesterday you guys shot us a bunch of
cool games we put a poll up on Twitter
and now we are playing alien ice Alesha
winner that is our winner
and that is what's going on today for
our eighth day of horror so let's get it
poppin yeah another one we both have not
played wrong with us yes I know good
things to be fair I've only recently
discovered like this year that I enjoy a
scary game I thought it was too scared
to play them now you just kind of get
like this adrenaline rush out of it yeah
I like we got our little stream family
here to support us we got you good
so we haven't tried this but I've heard
literally nothing but good things about
this game me too
and there's even like DLC that I
downloaded it downloaded with it and
yeah so I'm excited
chad is already warning us they're like
this game is scary watch out all right
let's do it already meet you you you
started I'll take the first shift yeah
exactly
I let you go first like engage whether
like I'm gonna be freaked out fair
enough fair enough because to be fair I
feel like the only thing that's really
horrified me so far has oh yes so these
are the DLCs yeah let's go to in between
regular yeah let's kick it off
sasame you are already setting the tone
for us head-tracking
hmm oh we don't have the camera although
that sounds scary with it on maybe we
can turn like perfect purposely seeing
well we need the camera the PS oh yeah
so does that mean they like purposely
look at where you're looking so they can
set up the optimal jump scare is cuz
that's that's a lot hit that again we
got the bright light in front of us so
we want to be a little extra maybe a
little extra we are in general in
general by the way you guys I like
totally just spent the last half hour
like taking the best selfie I have
everything I have to show it to you
before we before we start the best of
you I've ever taken I wanted to like
it's so good all those spooky filters on
snapchat that's right this edge is the
scariest game ever I swear every time we
have a scary stream someone recommends
some another scariest game of all yeah
next year we got to do the whole damn
fun yes
I radar a final report of the commercial
starship Nostromo third officer
reporting are you feeling in a skipping
movie other members of the crew I guess
it depends right like how long it is and
can you skip Lambert Parker I can't
breath for times sake
okay I think time has been our biggest
like enemy what it has
I'm Samuels I work for the company
specific scaredy Weaver in space y'all
know what's up we just want to get to
the to the get CS Nate's games back in
the building
what's up playing a little alien
isolation we kind of skipped ahead so we
can start playing wish us luck time has
not been on our side these streams and
we get into the no we're doing it for
you guys
plus you know we're the only ones who
haven't played this yet so you guys
already know that's fine yeah please
sign in oh no I got a remember my
password that is horror that is it's
true okay okay it's just on my card okay
explore explore there's our space pods
or sleep pods search who's robbing fools
take this item yeah objection get
dressed yeah it's cold in here I'm naked
cigarettes get out of the little tube
see what I'm wearing really let's find
some clothes apparently you can't wear
clothes in like cryo sleep or whatever
yeah
I personally oh look at that that's
funny there might be other Simpsons I
used to have one of those really run
around naked naked
it's not personal surgery clothes got to
be in here yeah which one is mine oh man
I hate these actually when they open the
locker and something scary isn't it yeah
watch it start off right away like he
knows are haunted by aliens oh there's
my clothes nice I guess okay that's me
Ripley boom mission accomplished
games over guys thank you for joining us
cheesy bathroom shower I'm dressed and
then I got this scary
power must be Monday yeah I haven't had
my coffee it's not here now you're
wasting water I know this game is going
to have a few jump scares oh boy Thanks
oh this is how you save games okay well
I just saved the game you know what no
not yet
what am i doing don't no need for that
okay go back and turn off the water
we're good we're good
it's only a spaceship I'm assuming just
getting my buttons here if there are any
there's like a poo yeah those are mine
hello they're all ours there's no one
here what the heck right that seems to
be a common spooky game tree yeah where
that is everyone be alone and searching
this is alien isolation after all makes
sense yeah I was just thinking that okay
there's a green light that looks good
I'm gonna head this way yeah you mean
yeah this game ain't so scary guys not
good very much doubt it's neither
okay she's uh I don't like your attitude
excuse you you can only use each save
phone once so use my new hates games pro
tip right there
Wilson thank you yeah
the other maybe one or two days ago he's
like hey guys it's me Nate's games and
he's got the new Nathaniel Wilson
rebranding rebranding damn it do I have
to listen to this stuff you have the key
should I really do you think she'll give
me a key or something okay no you know
you're excellent there we go
but that was an objective we're so
impatient we they have gotten
increasingly more impatient yeah let's
get you the scares we're ready jook jook
what up Shingo there is areas no Samuels
wooden mules excuse me Samuels did you
wake up what Ford's gonna strum oh yes
and what I'm this close I feel like I'm
playing Skyrim I've worked engineering
jobs on ships like this it literally
took me like three hours I mean my
Skyrim coffee we talked she seems
nervous she's a school they should help
us with any legal issues
oh cool do I have an alien in my belly
that would explain something go to the
sandals dipped what the heck
he was Snake Plissken in the chasis
xenomorph for the win hell yeah we can't
wait
oh it's for looking around corner really
peeking oh whoa that was a little scary
oh yes protip okay how about okay all
right Samuel wait up
damn I know he was on the move you were
boring me and then you dipped this the
same places earlier yeah but I think the
story's unlocked
there's the bridge yeah this was yeah
you're right for sure hope you all had a
restful journey below took a few years
and a lot of contracts to refit she pays
for herself now you said we're
approaching Sevastopol station but we
don't pick I believe your contact is
Marshall waits is that right all hail
Sevastopol and arrange boarding with him
good
let's get this done a man says their
routine in and out Connor how are we
doing
sure routine briefing
you can watch the approach I knew it I
was like the second he said that I was
like we gotta go find it now
know it oh good it's right there is it
yeah it's going Oh Oh give me that
briefing file okay this is our routine
ass mission right guys switch to
monitors you know our friend with sweat
damage it looks like damage punch up 74
tight angle looks like the drydock bay
is screwed at you I think this game came
out and Mike what year was it 2014 or
2015 or something like that it looks
pretty it it does we're looking this up
at the moment yeah I was like got it now
it was pretty good yeah it's October 7
2014
cool as the initial early stage oh yeah
sometimes the cutscenes like hide the
fact that it's loading it ok now we're
making up for it yeah ok we missed some
crash yeah the second she said is that
normal damage I was like oh yeah yep
we're due this is what we wanted though
yeah
I let it really begin I feel like you
should have started here I kind of think
that dude what does everyone's go-to
game for Halloween says sneak mmm I
don't know if I have a go-to game but I
definitely have like go to movies and
music
yeah find help is the objective
excellent
I'm suited up yes I'm not sure but we
have been playing a lot of spooky games
this past week or so should I say yeah
but I'm with you Bridge I don't think I
have a game I play every maybe we should
sing why not you know what why not and
we go all the way back to the beginning
though it oh really
that would there we go
only once though yeah I guess all
Luigi's Mansion three Friday the 13th
the game those are great games
please wait oh no it was they going over
here right I can run now yeah running in
space go to movie is sauce is AJ red saw
okay yeah those are definitely scary
you're scary for like different reasons
they're like scary because someone
actually came up with that story and
made a movie at work so that someone
literally thought up these ideas
that's scary not gonna cross you yeah
yeah run in jook jook okay that's a suit
room that's the first room oh yeah you
went in a little circle I did
everything's blocked off maybe I do have
to go that way it's gonna just avoid the
fire what do you think Persia everything
else hey we just say we just save yeah
you're living you learn Yolo no ain't
Yolo down here huh okay they won't allow
it
damn okay well I want to put that out so
where's like though yeah let's go back
and find like a oh yeah there we go oh
noise noise nice perfectly human-sized
vents
ooh snake said Resident Evil remake is
go to game asked for movies Texas
Chainsaw Massacre and for music anything
from carpenter Brett I don't know what
that is but Texas Chainsaw Massacre yeah
that's a good go to movie ok we made it
past the fire let's go you need help
we're two aliens at I don't think we
know that that's a thing yet oh yeah
right where are my friends about that
folder come up I can't even access this
let's try the sheriff Corbin email still
ablaze and Carols thanks chief folder
corrupted okay space bleh block block
ooh narrow path someone's been here
though that was meant to happen yeah oh
my god that was more of an audio scary
aliens can use the Vince alien sized
event correction alien sizes yeah I'm
doomed guys what is the scariest game of
all time okay so I feel like that's
definitely um up to your personal
preference but so far all this play it's
slender the arrival freakin destroyed me
and my soul I wonder if the first Lander
man is scarier I don't think so cuz
they'd probably try to make the second
one scarier but we had a good time
streaming that the other day
yeah we don't around a couple days ago
if you're at all interested it's on our
GameSpot Channel as a VOD but I do okay
so to be fair the scary game I played
when I was younger that actually made me
not play scary games for forever until
this year was fear really yeah
and that was like a super long time ago
is the first time I played a game that
like purposely tried to jump scare the
crap out of me and I'd hate it and I was
like oh my god this is really really
scary I think I hated it because I
didn't like that it made me like super
chicken like [ __ ] high-pitched
shrieking like screaming from me of how
scared I was getting and that was a long
time ago in a really low gain now it's
like scary games have been kicked up a
notch they have all this technology like
the VR five nights at Freddy's that was
pretty scary too yeah I heard the
Resident Evil in VR was really scary I
think I need something to use this
properly oh let me try again yeah the
power level there we go Pokemon hands
down scary number one I'm with you
snake so Silent Hill 2 yeah that's
suddenly been a super popular one we
played it on the first day of horror but
honestly I just we didn't have enough
stream time to be able to really enjoy
that game for what it was but even just
the beginning was definitely kind of
restore the power
that's the rule 11 do down in super on
video oh man yeah I had power source we
checked that room one more time this
case I missed anything I got to look up
this Vistage game that Nine Inch colas
has been talking about spooky stuff huh
Oh keep it in mind for next year we
definitely have to do this again ooh
it's an indie horror game survival
horror of course
so what Slenderman originally I feel
like the indie ones are really like
what's that huh radio michael says this
is actually the scariest game I've ever
played really oh man we're in for a
treat
you see what I mean it's like scary in
different ways catches different people
right like what do you find terrifying I
know I mentioned it yesterday on stream
but like I watched this episode of
minefield from the new season that
they're like trying to find the scariest
thing and they talk about all these
little things that affect us and then
they talk about people who either had
damage to or didn't have their amygdala
in their brain right and that basically
tells you what is scary pretty much yeah
and so beings like this do not scare
them at all
have no reaction whatsoever and I'm like
they're gonna do this their concept of
beer is different yeah like they don't
feel like they said even one person like
had someone come up to him and try to
mug them with like a knife or something
and they weren't even scared they were
just like I'll kill you you know they
tried to like you know scare them back
and it totally worked they they were
fine but it's so interesting that little
pieces of your brain literally are
designed to like make you feel fear I'm
just trying to get the power back on
y'all got some scraps that's the power
yeah with the power at their map yeah
hey perfect okay noise good looking at
Persia oh man I can already tell this is
gonna be so creepy do I need to go back
upstairs to access that room yeah yeah
the ladder okay
okay explorin yeah a little bit this is
our first time playing this game okay
what are you guys doing for Halloween my
god I am looking at trailer for this
viscid skin oh I get 1 million percent
like PT vibes uh-oh it's in like a
creepy little house Kenneth says the
Last of Us is actually pretty scary hell
yeah definitely scary in concept too
like you don't want that to be a thing
well that's the room I need to be in
y'all yeah as act that's what I was
thinking to you cuz like most these
games we haven't really played yet so I
don't know where the like meaty parts of
it are like Slenderman that was right
from the beginning it was scary from the
start but like this one and Silent Hill
like those needed some time to get to
the into it into it they're like real
juicy like jump scare price of this game
or at the games period low on meds dang
we were struggling on this ship I might
have been playing audio from that
oh really yeah like I can't hear it here
but it was definitely playing I think
it's Argus we were thinking about trying
to squeeze in another afternoon stream
today but we got a we gotta wait and
find out if we're able to do that first
[Music]
that was probably in the email look I
found this thing okay time to check back
a journal here maybe yeah since I didn't
read those emails I knew it was gonna
happen but it's nearby I have the code
you know what save time and google it
yeah why not yeah where are we right now
like I don't know we are base by
terminal Oh Sebastopol still pull
terminal we came here for this 20 29 31
oh [ __ ] okay forget this email going
back Thank You Persia good whew
Google shmoo go baby I mean I only know
to do that for like these older games
right cuz they've been out for a long
time yeah
oh I got it okay hold up JK
he's the terminal and go I'll a utility
first start again oh okay I see
cool okay yeah
all right try 1851 they changed it codes
on us that's all right
the chat is saying the email for sure I
looked over it at the terminal they're
making me work y'all but thank you for
helping us out
I tried to - cheater yeah we try - yeah
no harm
okay try zero two four zero I'm checking
the e I'm back after the terminal the
first time move it in the first email
that I saw
there we go we hope you all those codes
way go the way they came or the way they
went I would go the way they went like
though don't leave me wake up y'all
they definitely left us though watch
yeah uh-huh locked us out
jerks having some friends over for some
horror movies and gaming just good times
with good people that is awesome no
honestly like that's one of my favorite
things to do oh three four zero aha I
think you do have to go this is okay I
think this is like a little bonus room
anyway Oh more blueprints hahaha huh
it's a goodies room we love these we're
in a vault on terrace Oh what is this oh
right there you can build stuff like
your medkit sensors it's because you
collect scrap nice yeah ooh that's kind
of cool on the fly yeah that's really
cool we'll need that for crafting our
items those guys straight-up left
without me yep so I guess go back all
the powers on I'm gonna try that door
over here oh the way they came was over
there oh yeah I tried that but now that
the powers on this door should be
unlocked look at that hmm
[Music]
where's this alien oh boy right say
something
Oh No
Oh quick session worth it remember that
space key and it was not a scary game to
buy something and it scared the crap out
of me
that was great I remember that she said
what the hell happened here let's find
out
it is okay there was a way to craft
Stephen said I wish this got a sequel
well they did release like two two packs
a dlc way i have men kids i picked one
up but how do I use it
[Music]
good question good question
check your corner it says Michael now
starting now because start checking my
corner we're like blazing through I
heard rumbling that doors locked
okay it's this kidding oh we're still a
chapter or two away from the alien
alright let's rush again Russ Russ going
upstairs okay what's that about they
need to eat a Senzu bean damn they don't
have these on board Lillian is actually
in Torrance generally leaving without me
really
y'all messed up for that oh great
going into locked yeah Oh guys even
doing that situation you see the ship
flying away without you yeah knowing
damn well you're in space
I've been played the Blair Witch game
but the movie terrifies me
so I was like really scared when that
was the Blair Witch feel like oh crap
damn it y'all left without me I can't
believe it yeah well I mean it is called
isolation right alien isolation which I
should I go right now and crying like if
I'm being realistic yeah this is like
you don't want me to design a game the
main character right now be like [ __ ]
like crazy like I don't know what it is
it's all over for us now I'm gonna be
eaten eat no no it's like the concept of
space is already it's a big fake right
like you can't even step out we double
check something only protection
squeezing through you'll meet a bald guy
gonna have a little trouble and then the
alien oh boy it is dark in here yeah
I on torch required Oh why is the music
doing that alright
so chat says keep going the way you were
going up the stairs
happy Halloween yes Michael thank you
and happy Halloween to everybody yeah
thank you all for tuning in up these go
down the other service cool I think I
just missed that second flight of stairs
going down that's right because they
were blocked off thank you jackie has it
so helpful we're trying to get to the
scares you know absolutely locked brush
it down brown well crap if you could
pick one horror game to be made into a
movie what game would you pick so snake
that's a good question let me think
let me see cuz you got to think about
like storyline and stuff too right
there's something like slender although
it's a scary game I don't think it would
be a scary movie even though it's like a
scary tale and like the story no I don't
think I have an answer right away you
know yeah I have to like think and it
has to be something else isn't already a
movie
like aliens
that's me we already flare which that's
movie already here another terminal cuz
I notice in that email that had the code
the code was like yellow just seems like
I was double checking for any codes also
there's the save a dead space for a
movie yeah Oh that'd be a great idea
although it's basically a even though
it's movie like man Amazon probably even
though they do go for a movie
we got some power back I want to get
back there to like it's all blocked off
this place went through some things you
know wait did we turn on the power
yeah okay but I don't know if that'll
affect this store it said I needed
something specific didn't it oh yeah
Israel said what about the other way
around what about scary movie turned
into a game that's good one that's a
good one
what's a good scary movie I've seen
recent like something like insidious
would be good in VR also like you would
have to be a VR game I think because
they really push the jump scares in that
movie go back to the shop hatch on the
ground shop II is this where the shop
was I think incident back where you were
somewhere Oh
notice a shop or a hatch let's see
stranger things would be cool too as a
game like but not as a style of game
that they just get released which is
like oh yeah you got to go around stairs
again yeah here we go
Ritchie the marathon what up swifty
playing a little alien isolations for
the first time I'm seeing this a lot
yeah I have a feeling the alien wrote
that okay so there's a hatch in the shop
yeah Cornish and the flow appreciate you
guys I get that
wow man really appreciate you a little
you know family here alright they want
to see us get scared though huh oh it's
it's on we're getting into darker titers
being louder yeah no flashlight ass
okay Wow
Duke wait there yeah staircase but the
way out ya little thing there it's our
game man clowns oh that's a good idea
have you watched it one or two Persia I
watched the first one yeah what do you
think I it just creeped me out because I
don't really like Thailand place is
falling apart that was cool they played
it they're a success hmm
I think what was Maurice Garry was like
the balloon right like I watched like
this new top five video and this guy was
definitely getting like followed around
by a balloon no it was kind of eerie at
first but then towards the end of the
video he like went into a room and a
balloon like turned the corner and went
his room superfast I was like nope nope
nope from me I started this game a lot
of times and disappear then started
again that's why I remember the start of
it really well says Orhan oh dang this
is not a new game this came out in 2014
yeah but it still looks super good so we
have one creepy dude running around yep
unidentified apparently we weren't the
only ones left behind but what was he
running from guys maintenance jack okay
there my way in space is real soon I was
just watching nukes top-5 isn't that
channel awesome that channel has so many
yeah yeah I binge watched those ghost
videos all the time I don't like
watching the ones that are real life
scary stuff I just like watching that
ghost ones and paranormal boo-boos yeah
I need that to get through this for sure
actually show you go for it oh wait is
that that looks locked doesn't even look
like a real door okay so far it seems
like they do a good job at not giving
you too many extra paths so you have to
like make crazy decisions on which way
to go yeah which is nice that doors lock
that there was locked wait
dang that one's definitely yeah bar they
any other ones next to it like this no
that's a window okay
all right person you want it all right
all right watch aliens gonna help me
yeah in this right now is well program
says Kenneth yeah I did hear that the
alien gets some AI that helps him be
more scary smart okay what we want hope
we see one soon
yeah well we didn't see the ball up
going yet which is Chad is like this
ready for us to get scared I know they
know what okay that's why was this adore
ek through yeah but there was more doors
I think over there or some no I'm sorry
I'm trippin yeah beans a son yet lots so
we need a jack to open that door it said
Hey okay three times I learned is the
magic number
[Laughter]
looky Adam ah
Nate's games is like oh you will you
will find him wah ha hey cool okay more
light in here yeah there is my light
which means there must be something over
here
yeah something worth collecting Michael
just press X on everything sounds like
it's a collectathon
alright alright alright hey there's a
stair over these bodies here real quick
sorry guys the other in the way oh oh
now we're we're specifying who were
we're saying that to a lot of open doors
yeah we like that what did that say wait
lie to us oh no don't know somebody lied
to us just a liar I know so many
daughters oh yeah well I'm gonna assume
my jack is in there yeah it looks like a
maintenance room damn it dude I knew
that was like just by looking at it but
I walked up to the minions alright so we
go around
[Music]
oh so he's still alive well threw him in
the maintenance lockup he said but that
guy's sold the Jag dang so was there
something that's the guy there was
something shiny I swear oh the bad thing
okay
that ball thing because it would might
just be decorative a news crawlspace
it's like nice right now but later I'm
gonna be like no no yeah you're gonna
probably hate these crawl spaces later
see why she didn't climb so
Jagga do you like that Gary oh boy
oh all right yeah all right so I can
leave here with the jack nice there we
go the ones you wonder why I said
crossly crawlspaces later on equal death
testify really oh my god graphics Gramp
yes alien trilogy is one of my favorite
like well I originally played it on the
Sega Saturn but it's on the PlayStation
1 also it's so good
the maintenance check and uses a weapon
I like the sound of that
Oh plenty of stuff here goodies we
should learn to craft but maybe some
other but see how what we need to we
might have to start grumbles no this
game isn't new it's the 2014 game alien
isolation it's new to us because we
haven't played so if you're at all
interested stick around I just needed
the jacks open that means yeah mates
Jack Oh cutscene or it still cool I knew
it okay this is the ball game
I'm gonna shoot me yeah traitor Elise
come on
I'm Ripley where'd you come from
Ripley off-station [ __ ] there's no ships
here there are now well that's good news
because things are not so good here
something blue just now rock this whole
place
but lady that's the least of our
problems
yeah yeah yeah on the station something
you should have seen King I don't want
to hear that we should have seen a few
we've made a grave mistake okay that
means we can't die right now
Axl I was boarding with two colleagues a
VA we got separated by the blast can you
help me find them why cuz you seem to
know your way around I mean why what's
in it for me a place on the ship I know
I can trust you I need to find comms
I need to contact my ship
this you know that has given us the real
there they're spoiling us but I feel
like this guy survived yeah all right
let me go save that save point it was an
earring here anything I think if you
press the PlayStation button it'll I'm
sorry the yeah that one you know there's
a safe spot hell of oh there we go
wizard this is the last
Spooky's theme maybe we're debating
about one more this afternoon yeah we're
gonna try to squeeze one in in the
afternoon
but um yeah as far as on yeah we
actually have to work yeah yeah you know
I doing all this to save because scat
scat chat scared me see I can't even
talk now hit him with the Jag and get
his gun can I do because that would be
great I'll be quick
well he's gonna be waiting for me at
this okay one thing at a time y'all we
just got a safe room somewhere right
that's like just behind that door no way
no way is this it is the way I Q really
hit that that uh that's unfortunate
no way damn that's it all right we're in
there let's just we got this and I you
just can died that's all yep
Oh or Hunt says there are safe spots
along the way don't worry I mean I don't
particularly mine the spoilers
considering this games been out for a
really long time
yeah but maybe not for check because it
yeah don't worry about us but maybe
don't spoil it in the chat okay with the
attitude yes we can't even swing I tried
damn it Kenneth I'm going left what's
happening here oh I did it too fast
I was already holding down else you all
right she left like before she even
alright what's fine door number one was
that you following me back there had to
keep my distance can take any chance it
was him
knew it stick close to me what whoa who
are you I'm John
this is Ringo they're just some [ __ ]
we haven't got time for this come on
my name is Ringo we're trying to get to
cops can you help us seems same story
there yes Orhan in the chat don't run
trouble incoming that was about to go
down y'all and Chad is hinting at uh-oh
no maybe I was supposed to stay over
there no no I'm just glad you saved
yeah I've been sick ever since you guys
are like what the hell was that about
why are you so damn aggressive damn did
he kill the c-4 that we this ship of
yours is the real McCoy man you better
be the real McCoy
hold up let me get the elevator oh okay
fine okay I think you definitely killed
us alone
yeah maybe back up I don't like this no
person don't go on yeah you go Chris
okay all right
elevator clear I thought you were gonna
get it I know we're hiding behind him
like I know what's going on all right
fight stance read each other's head
Chuck what air what hair boy yeah when
we get to my ship I need to know what's
going on right [ __ ] now Oh like I
said there's a killer
don't say that Michael not one where in
here there's an alien an elevator a
person has to become something else
Michael with the Simpsons reference my
cat's breath smells like cat food
I'm staying here I was kidding I know
you okay there you go oh yeah
something's gonna happen cuz the game
just like Luke straight-up says don't
trust that guy
whatever the choice at the moment oh we
need to move this way Oh what was that
armed guys way off are you crazy
there's no way off at least we're safe
down here for how long
what if they come for us shame yeah shut
up
you're making me nervous
trouble you'll have to go random follow
me
oh yeah there's a bunch of suitcases I
don't think we're meant to go that way
oh great of course how convenient this
guy this guy
fans of yours I've had run-ins with
those guys before they don't like
strangers even nice guys like me I'm
sure Wow huh tune your change darling
you want to go and say hello it's your
fear of those guns on for sure someone
should be doing something they are it's
called surviving this guy's like an
[ __ ] but he's like helping us we'll
roll with him for now he's our [ __ ]
yeah we don't we don't have a choice
Mike Michael says if he dies they close
the axle that's the objective
this little hideout okay I'll get down
here for the week nice they were right
okay it can get pretty dark around here
you should take that flashlight over
this headset flashlight the old-school
Xbox Live yeah be careful not to flash
it around you don't want to get caught
let's go okay
hmm oh there's a battery meter on the on
the bottom this week this way oh yeah
this is prime alien environment this
dude's gonna die nice and dark over
there
use your flashlight find the venn
entrance okay I'm opening and I think
we're gonna fly out eat me because you
know that's what they like oh no I don't
like that yeah but that one's like one
of those blocked off one Hey
another block there we go
Axl was it he can unlock him he's good
yeah um it's got a red spray-painted
lying around it which mean you go first
bare Axl there you go Axl do you thing
buddy
yeah leave that gun behind I don't want
to go in here
waiting on you looking at me stay here
too low
why you think it's a long row I would be
in such a rush like every second yeah
the alien suddenly having lunch are you
now where'd everyone go
bingo torrents so that's your ship
[Music]
there's always something going down
Willy I like those guys and on our
friends for everybody besides me why not
now I'm paranoid now yeah I'm saving
every time protic you mean this what be
any quieter bro
were stick around while I check our
stock crap something's like should I go
over there what's the move yeah what's
axel doing oh wait I should follow him
Raymond yeah I lost him take on I heard
him we still got to get through there
the door at the end oh okay the door at
the end yeah nice excuse which one of
you checked our supplies last generator
the [ __ ] is that supposed to mean hey
he's been with me the whole time we're
missing food I've just come from there
sealed tight Michael put planes like use
the flashlight to find axel do I escape
to the vent afterwards
I'm thinking so cuz they'll know that
you know where you're at yeah maybe prep
that I don't know whatever you want
this first
and then I don't know where this leads
but it's like right in front of them
guns pointed at you you're on the other
side of the door
forget this I'm ready gun did good I
would to SB gaming says happy Halloween
guys nicely done purchase yeah thank you
smooth enough Todd you're slow act no I
don't think we're kneeling anymore dang
good we need to activate both consoles
at the same time to open it I'll do this
one you got to be an engineer in every
horror game that's the rule we're gonna
remarry your soul to axe hole ok axe
ready ready on three one two three huh
Wow one two three Longwood
goodbye friend Oh save him okay go go go
run for your life I'm real slow now all
of a sudden yeah with the lock you move
it nah really you only shot him
point-blank in the face because he was
going to kill me you saved my life
survival do you understand
still creepy what is he in a place full
of yeah we know what that is alien goo
yep
welcome into the Vince chat said it all
along
no Morgan did he drop his gun we're out
I don't care I'm out of here purchase
that F this also Ripley is like like the
wait for it oh no oh yeah
is a big No
oh my god hurry up I know
look at this BART train right now me as
always something's there don't I think
use your flashlight no what the heck
messed up
now the the eeriness is kicking in
[Music]
there it is it landed come on come on
come on come on okay okay okay you know
we made it I did fill my levels of like
fear rising no absolutely and they're
waiting for the music all right here you
go
me yes okay it is your turn I'm gonna
say this wrong but Montez is beating to
the soundtrack seriously like as it was
going my heart rate was like we're good
we could argue yeah yep rest in peace
axe hold
swifty safe for now yeah boy all right
so we're still making our way to come
Crouch walk maybe no okay I have to go
Crouch walk with what I need to run is
there a safe way in this elevator
doesn't appear from what I wonder she
booked it into that
[Music]
we have multiple hiding Walker good to
know oh man wonderful I said okay that
was your first glimpse but the alien
will be back real soon
[Laughter]
we can't wait I didn't grab as good I
didn't know if that was an option I just
got scared and ran oh wait no wait are
we calling it back oh yeah yeah yeah
yeah how'd you turn on the flashlight
Orhan said come on Axl isn't that bad
besides shooting that guy if you ask me
he didn't help us out he did he served
his purpose
yeah um there was a green door on your
right
was that where we came in from oh no
okay there's a lot to unpack here this
looks like the correct way though there
is a lot on that a lot of doors out of
isolation yeah nice and unlock psych
wait yeah okay wait up
no wait
man I guess we should have grabbed the
gun great dark let's go hide okay I get
it we got to lure them out hide then run
back in and take the elevator okay but
the elevator appeared to be broken and
the music stopped hello yeah there's one
Locker what about this way I don't have
a weapon locked
Oh love extra oh then Vincent Vincent
someone yeah right Thanks
although I'm a little scared to go in
here oh no it's time
oh no it's time ooh we've got loot oh we
definitely should have picked up his gun
oh my God why did we do we're doomed
yeah that's carried me love it
what okay we're just back here that's
another good place to hide I guess I
didn't know that you guys are actually a
not trolling us about picking out this
gun all right
too late now I think I improperly
rewired that speaker system Nate is
helping us out oh they won't come back
until you get well now where was it was
it down there
okay I'll try no one's on my tail
oh you can go back but do we want
unstable
[Music]
hmm power available zero there you go I
turn on the speakers at least oh [ __ ]
hmm yeah should I go back to those banks
go back let's go maybe they're out
searching for you now I'm unarmed
maybe we could pick up one of their guns
yes swing at them or sneak past them
anyone at the door anymore
no but it's locked is it that's red oh
you're right okay
but there's a staircase yeah just go
over there and check it out it doesn't
look like anyone's here it might tell us
what we need to do next hmm loot goodies
give me the loot yeah yeah yeah did they
give us a more a-hole revolver because
that would have been convenient
oh boy Ryan
I know she dropped something easy fix
okay find a data wait
yeah go with that okay go where were
they coming from though that's on in
like the first floor they're gonna split
up and look for me where are they - I
need to know where they are
Oh oh no that does not look like the
vent we want to be in that had alien
dust in it Balian does
we're hunted the sprays are you right
now oh my god oh yeah we don't have time
to search I think they totally you might
move in with you Gigi real chat you
think they're gonna go out oven oh look
at my health I can't I'm doomed
hmm build the health kit no flare no med
kits but can I build one No oh I know
right
dang it Michael said how did he not see
how did I not die wouldn't you like
ready this gun I was like Oh GJ we
didn't get shot twice no yeah look at my
middle yep chat oh my gosh he's gonna be
like right there could you find the gun
against it is anybody in there
yeah straight up I thought sure heal
yourself I don't have a med kit yeah
maybe we should just die inside of it
oh my god what to do I think I'm just
gonna I might have to take the El here
guys maybe or Fon I tried to build a
medkit I don't think I have enough stuff
yet
hey might not have the research the
properties okay okay I don't know why
I'm doing this
let's just hope this does something ah
that's it for me want to give it a go
I just got whacked oh man it's hard it
does load current save okay but if
you're ready I mean you know pressure
cuz I present I don't know what I'm
doing and I don't know if I can give
good advice alright here we go
we still have a little life hello from
Sevastopol you do oh okay well it looks
like I we might have enough stuff to
build a medkit l1 to build
ah cool and then why can I put the other
look at the progress it filled out all
the way and we have a make you so much
thank you I would love to make another
one yeah why not
I wonder how much help these things give
you woohoo noise hold it to activate yay
hey there we go alright well thank you
so much chats looking out for us earlier
Nate said uh take them out one by one
maybe we can like stealth melee them you
were looking out for number one it's
okay
I mean chest that we could go back to
the gun area yeah I'm gonna take the
train again
really oh man that would cause all the
tension though you know is that it is
that it you're gonna take okay both
always leave
okay yep here again maybe this time she
doesn't have to see us damn it here girl
yeah whoo how do I like put this away ah
yeah no we can't I'm just gonna walk
around with this thing in my hand
no Nate says you can go back for the gun
from dead axle hmm yeah that might be
the only way guys how do I switch back
to my own weapon because r2 was some
melee do you still have it
yeah but now with oh okay she's just
okay switch myself okay all right now
you gotta pick up that thing she dropped
before they they come through the room I
don't think they come out at this point
and access to
oh you pad but okay goddamn circuits are
fried an easy fix
just need to find a new data center data
cell mm-hmm
okay we know they come from over there
yeah where can we successfully hide and
find a day to sell that one on the right
looking the area sensor Shh
joke's on you got to use that
l1 or something
[Music]
dajin we their aim can't be that good
that's okay I've better a needle that
one's locked going through the right is
easier dang
ooh all right it's gonna be one of those
yep
I'm a little sad no aliens yet I know
our whole stream has been as getting to
the aliens and bodied by other humans
great Tim all right I need to step up my
levels of sneaky chats with us so
there's like take him out sneak around
him oh yeah where are you
I saw something in the window like all
right so it's seeing plan take what guy
yelling and turns around and run
do I get some stealth actions yeah is
there a safe point out here it would be
all right let me go activate this
cutscene right quick oh I dropped this
controller and I think it misses it
really - it
she's gonna go
it's gonna go nark on us now we get
I ran to go get the homies so the data
cell is in that room it is okay and
access to
she was trying to hack the elevator
security circuits are fried easy fix
just need to find a new dataset easy fix
they split up
remember the first time you saw me think
they'll see me a family they saw me in
the vent
oh I started shooting at me alright so I
see homeboy over there in the room
alright this one we can climb up if you
turn around but if you want to go that
way I can go up yeah like if you go
forward a little bit there was an option
I think to climb at least I think it's
only if you fall down to there oh you're
already on the top part okay my bad
cyborg man we don't know why they want
to kill you though he asks nothing
suspicious here
yeah it's just a vent she walked that
way well hombre is on the left right
there was someone on the lot earlier I
don't know if their patterns repeat
every time
I'm so painfully low he's gonna be over
here I kind of feel like that is the
case I don't think we have the motion
detector yet do we
setec I know was it oh it is it is it is
it was taking a kkkk crap you're right I
should have went the other way
what's circle to it pull up that it
pulls up that like like blue can that
detect people if you hold it down oh
shoot I'm not gonna make it in here but
I'm going anyways oh no this was the
moment you got stuck in Leslie what is
it oh the dead end yeah all right so I'm
gonna try to go back the way oh boy oh
boy oh they're both over there yeah oh
that's good for me I wonder how many
there are total I think there's three
okay
I hope thank you sir you the two guys in
the girl I don't remember from that
first scene though no no no one did
goodbye goodbye cruel world
yeah yeah false alarm bro he's walking
up here is he yes oh wow
good use of the peekaboo hate that guy
ding get that melee out oh yeah you're
right there is four get your ass ok cool
right that's right nothing to see you
are we trying to get to that room over
there though I'm just going this way if
he sees me rest in pieces yeah
why he's gotta go in there I gotta go in
there
welcome i'ma wait till he comes back out
and goes over there okay you got that
there's a door here door
I can't just gonna
get opened is this some room I'm
supposed to go in
Oh tech support yeah that would make
sense all bad this feels so wrong oh go
away glad I found you guys what is going
on
[Music]
okay okay I think I'm good to go now
yeah yeah oh okay they make you funny
cuz I feel like this is further than
we've gotten so far um is that really a
sneak attack probably just whack him
with there I think she went downstairs
we're definitely going the right way
because I'm not going down there no way
that's right with her cow what up we
reach at
we're just um shook we're in the thick
of it right now yeah we're surrounded
and there's also a slight delay there is
yes but appreciate you guys in chat you
guys have been helping us out a lot like
100% more than you know at the flare all
right I'm scared this then is very green
yeah that we're you okay I can't tell if
they're coming down here or not but I
feel like this room has winning save
point
ah oh really I think so yes yay okay min
Han says please don't run a revolver
we are strapped y'all already and we got
some ammo fully loaded man and we have
five minutes
of course we find the gun with five
minutes sell I also got a key card so
yeah although I don't know if this
do I think it's progress a dead guy
bullet holes
it definitely has what I need maybe
someone's dead but it's like are they
bullet holes are they stab wound hmm
Andy says I finished this using the
oculus rift and it was the best VR
experience I've had so far
oh my damn this in VR did he have
anything on him I miss it I was reading
um yeah he did but a little nothing in
Britain
what what
[Music]
is that our comps might have been she
called it the flight recorder stay
focused
Oh have your gun handy
[Music]
I do not like the sound I saw something
that said you 200 you can shift these
left and right
[Music]
what is that you might have to connect
all those things so that they're all
touching
maybe or something something like that
tank
[Music]
yeah maybe one of them is in the way of
something
there we go hide where oh god oh good
god there's nowhere now yeah and I don't
think there's the aliens coming for me
huh I don't see any vents
[Music]
I don't know where to go
I'm locked in the door didn't opened it
it's all green life I'm not sure what's
going on I need something
mmm-hmm none of these are green anymore
so either messed up or I did it okay the
music's misleading that makes me feel
better
[Music]
think about geological here I just take
a cell
all right now does your device work
[Music]
what oh you have to put those pieces
together to make that shape up top ah
tricky oh I see I see
yeah there you go that one yeah yeah my
hands are sweaty no problem
that music yeah all right no we gotta go
back now that you know how to hack
things that's the door okay so looking
for me
[Music]
I'm like preparing to hide in here yeah
[Music]
to be afraid disable security lockdown
where is that a
[Music]
got it rad looks like we passed the
motion detector always it nah that would
have been useful I'm like Brodie extreme
time but I want to see the alien again
so I'm like kind of rushing it down a
little bit I'm with you
that's right I just went what oh you
think so yeah yeah I'm going tech shop
server her perception this one was one
that was lost but I open now
[Music]
okay check the keyboards keyboard oh I
am in the right room okay okay this guy
this looks like the where we what was it
like the security shut down one of these
terminals oh hey there is a big hello
from the Zeno bar don't be like that are
you back in control no it's not
he's ugly nose I'm hearing his tail at
me
hopefully get Sookie alright go take out
those people for me Rodrigo
[Music]
chat oh man
[Music]
I I just wanted to see if them
come back and music though I know
alright I gotta make it back to the
elevator
alright that's the plan here yeah now
that you got your hacking machine but
now there's an alien loose
where was that room oh what the man you
help the little map was it that one up
there I think I'm on a different or
maybe well what's behind you like yeah
they're really in this room you can get
that out of here now
hey wait oh I'm going the wrong way
yeah yeah I think it's all in a
different floor and so I gotta go I
basically have to go the way he went
he's going upstairs to kill those people
for you I really don't like that it's
sick stop
I gotta go back upstairs I'm just gonna
hope he killed them already I'm out dang
it dang oh it was this one yeah I think
restore back so many stairs uh yeah here
we go there we go hacking the mainframe
nice that's fun yes they found each
other
you gotta get to that door why should I
do it well uses Jack's it was that the
way oh maybe not remember they use the
vent though to chat was telling us the
whole time I can see why this would be
really cool in be our little Hinson this
is the part of the game where you stop
sprinting and never press the sprint
button button again yeah
protip you're right you're right dang I
felt like it was a hey thanks Clive
yeah um we definitely did not save
anywhere near where we were right there
five minutes ago was our last save rat
Oh No ten minutes ago so well yeah we
got to see the alien again and
unfortunately that is all of our time
stream quite the build up there I'm
doesn't gonna keep this on like on my
cue my game queue to come back to this
because it was pretty fun yeah I'm
definitely strategic and you can't run
from the alien you know
orhan thank you I I realized that the
hard way actually I kind of thought it
was like a mini cutscene so that I had
like some time to run around like he was
just gonna focus on them I was mistaken
absolutely thank you guys so much for
tuning in
and hope you enjoyed our eight days of
horror we're gonna try to come back for
an afternoon stream for a little bit of
a bonus game but if we can't you know we
will be back on every weekday at 11 a.m.
because that is where game spotlight is
poppin we usually play you know anything
new or a new DLC or whatever is current
and pop in so I'm actually really
excited we got the OK to do some spooky
ins and play some old-school games and
so the old favorites yeah so we're doing
a little bit of everything you guys but
happy Halloween have a great one
stay safe out there and tons of can make
sure you brush your teeth after no
cavities here ok see you guys later bye
you